J'exhorte le baseball, je dirais les associés
comme la vie de l'argent, je ne nommerai pas mon
bébé que l'homme dur le plus proche, sache que si je
ne peux pas faire avec toi, fais vraiment bien,
ils se font jouer un comédien
quand tu es  ça va être des clips si impitoyables
et voyons des changements vous changez la
situation prendriez-vous juste le
premier coup dur êtes-vous en train de fermer
la rue d'accord
ce sont ceux qu'il doit exploser et
j'étais stupide de supprimer la compétence
très propre queue de glace eazy  -e et dr.  Dre Je
dois vous dire ici que vous êtes témoin de
différents stéréotypes de l'histoire vous avez une
voix unique que le monde a besoin d'entendre
ils ne le feront pas nw8 tuons-les en w-attendez
ce n'est que la pointe de l'iceberg
messieurs que se passe-t-il qu'avez-
vous  dans ce sac, vous vous moquez de moi, vous
ne pouvez pas comprendre que
le gang glamour de cette chanson a volé notre
art est le reflet de notre réalité
vous êtes censés être quelque part ce sont des
artistes le rap n'est pas un art vous pouvez
venir ici et harceler mes clients parce que
de ce à quoi ils ressemblent
écoute sois honnête avec toi je ne connais
rien au hip-hop mais je sais que
tu es spécial voulait être impliqué
dans cette vie de gangster ici nous allons dire
un peu la vérité aux gens qui est leur
mère c'est  Ce n'est pas les Crips et les Bloods, c'est
une menace du gouvernement fédéral
, nous pouvons prendre le contrôle de ce
[ __ ] de monde